Allen
oh the hollow hollow nor hello my name
is Abdul I come from Egypt is decently I
started studying here in Oldenburg hotel
today I'm free and want to look around
the town so cooking only Walden borges a
cycle friendly city which is why I'm on
a bike vegan is for her fart
side burn ich bin fear hunt I hadn't
cycles since I was 12 when Kyle
ah lonely - nobody rides a bicycle in
Cairo Wendy and here everybody does I
think it's great
hmm this is the Old Town Hall it has a
triangular shape behind hiya cows
thus is then that's the town's coat of
arms
ah the physical Diigo the house this is
the Dakota House just 500 years old not
as old as the pyramids but it's
beautiful although this is I'm for sure
but this chin in Alden boy what's great
about Oldenburg is the mixture of
history like the Old Town Hall and the
modern shops that mixture makes
Oldenburg special is of us mocked
Oldenburg I'm bazan de la stud
here's if a coffin I'll zoom here they
sell things from their vehicles I'm
seeing this for the first time in Egypt
they sell products on the street this is
unusual for me also be bullish from this
ah as good guru sir
there are spices here it's like in Egypt
except that here everything's
prepackaged in Egypt spices are sold
loose the coffin [ __ ] Vasa fun often
ah disclose the palace with it I've
heard a lot about this palace
this is uncool it's a large one for a
small town like Oldenburg I've heard
there's a great museum inside let's go
in in the winnings or less Envy again
you
vision how beautiful yeah
there are lots of portraits and lots of
gold here
I think the Dukes and counts must have
been very rich from VAR Zaire vice
first on the grand ballroom I've never
seen such a beautiful ballroom
other than what I like Oldenburg because
it's a small town
what's good about a small town is that
you can get anywhere in a few minutes
using a nice book as mine it's been a
great day in Oldenburg I really enjoyed
it bye Cheers